[Music]
so
the michael k williams death
overdose and four people have just been
charged with it
tell me the detail what the hell
happened here all right so
damien williams the united states
attorney for the southern district of
new york and key chance sewell the
commissioner of the new york city police
department announced that ervin
cartagena has been charged in a criminal
complaint unsealed yesterday in
manhattan federal court with a narcotics
conspiracy in which he distributed the
fentanyl-laced heroin that resulted in
the death of michael k williams and
who's michael williams the actor he was
on the wire oh
let me show you just in case you don't
know ah i needed the face most talented
dramatic actors i need every face speak
on it speak on it and if you guys aren't
familiar with fentanyl
it's really potent in that old school
like you know how the cop busts out the
knife with the duct tape package and
they go like that and they rub it in
their mouth to see if it's like cocaine
or whatever they don't do that [ __ ] no
more because
by poking it if it's fentanyl anyone
within like 10 feet will just pass out
once it gets to the air it'll pass out
so they don't do that anymore so if they
pop a trunk and they see like duct tape
[ __ ] they immediately have to call like
guys in suits like [ __ ] when they
come in that's how strong fencing is and
that's that's a actually a pretty recent
thing uh because um
or at least recent in terms of like it's
been huge because a lot of people like
have been setting out things on like
social media being like hey i'm not
saying it's you or this bubble but if
anybody happens to be doing like cocaine
in la just something you guys know a lot
of things are being laced with fentanyl
and you will die and the reason why they
lace it is because it's so [ __ ]
strong that they can cut everything like
wait a little bit you just need a little
bit of cocaine and put fentanyl in there
and i get the craziest high you've ever
felt but our cop shows turning [ __ ] now
because we're not going to do the
[ __ ] knife thing that's pretty
hardcore dude
come on there's going to be a loose
candle there doesn't it i gotta see that
dude it says fentanyl on it i gotta
check it
i've always been a loose cannon
you know me
i'm dead
that's the loose cannon bro
and he doesn't have a partner dude he
doesn't have a party this is a multicam
he wasn't he was a loose cannon yeah he
was
[Laughter]
i've never seen a cop show with the with
the soundtrack
i know a seinfeld cop
sex
so uh cartagena was arrested in puerto
rico just the other day and he's
expected to be presented tomorrow in
federal court in puerto rico
okay uh three other dudes robles cruz
and massey were also arrested and will
be presented today in manhattan federal
court before united states magistrate
judge stuart diary you went that far
basically they said that this whole
fentanyl thing is considered a public
health crisis and it has to stop deadly
opioids like fentanyl and heroin don't
care about who you are or what you've
accomplished they just feel feed
addiction and lead to tragedy they've
been there for a while though like
they've been saying this you know
what what makes them think that that's
gonna stop it i got an idea why don't we
make it illegal hmm
[Laughter]
of michael k williams receiving it on
the streets
why is he buying it on the street i
thought actors had like luxurious drug
dealers that come and deliver it high
quality and stuff you know and then they
have like a suitcase and they open it up
and they say we have many many kinds is
that an undercover coptic in their
pictures it looks like a cctv tv
they have them all over oh man hurts
scooter next time sucks it is he doesn't
have a car
he went to go to a droid you want a bird
scooter
i was a celebrity like that too i
wouldn't go out and handle the
transaction myself i'd have to send like
an underling to go like do it that's you
know what i mean so yeah like a like a
college intern that's trying to be in
entertainment and [ __ ] you know college
yeah yeah like yeah so trying to make
their way in yeah and then you when
you're free assistant work you know you
can tell them it's a drug deal you be
like hey go pick up this package at this
place from this person who's wearing
this thing here's a photo oh my my
[ __ ] uber guy's here go go downstairs
and go get it yeah you're like actually
wait take a bird yeah
which leads me to assume that when you
get like footage like this it's probably
like you know a lower point personal
addiction or something where it's like
not organized and not i mean at the end
of the day it's also like fentanyl-laced
heroin it's not like i guess your oh it
was heroin yeah
it's not your like white-collar kind of
drug you know what i mean it's
damn he's already been on the i wonder i
wonder if he had uh prescribed
painkillers and then he moved on to this
because
that's a big thing that's why uh heroin
made a huge comeback because uh you know
the whole opioid epidemic where people
were stuck getting prescription like
painkillers i don't think it's over
though no no but that's that's that's
what spiked up the heroin usage because
it died out for a minute and then it
came back because it's the same effect
that you get but it's stronger right so
then when people get off of their uh
painkillers and the doctor's like i
ain't gonna write you anymore and then
they start going to the streets that's
how heroin made a comeback how do you
take heroin
specifically like that's the only way
what's the spoon one yeah
so they just have fentanyl in that so
when you're like injecting yeah straight
to your bloodstream like that
[Music]
that's crazy i didn't know fentanyl
could be um injected like that and
that's probably what happened [ __ ]
weird because it only takes like the
smallest amount to kill you right yeah
when i saw that um that news thing on
like ig all the comments that were like
the top where people pissed that um
that
the law went so far as to find the guys
that gave it to him and they were like
they never do that for regular people
which is kind of true yeah
they don't if they don't go process like
junkie dies they're just like oh well
yeah oh i see well they're also not
gonna get put on the map if it's not a
high profile case yeah i mean like but
it is pretty cool like i didn't know
that they would go that far either yeah
i had no idea that four people get
prosecuted because you took drugs yeah
especially when uh you're in like puerto
rico already i know and like not even
domestic like yeah they caught a flight
to get this guy what's kind of like
remember the hollywood um hills
burglaries
and like most people who have their
houses burglarized their cops are like
yeah you're it's never never going to
see anything so yeah sorry about god
sure
life's the sound of a [ __ ] sometimes
okay sometimes you get robbed i don't
tell you
but then like you know paris hilton got
robbed and then like a couple other big
time uh actors got robbed and then they
[ __ ] took the whole ring down bro
like there's a movie about it was it was
it uh justin timberlake that stole from
everybody no
what this is a dream you had wait
not something it's a fever drink
did you guys see that one no never mind
it was it didn't it didn't it didn't get
it didn't get popular oh so with ben
affleck
no that's the account no i don't know
i don't know wait
there is a movie called the accountant i
don't know if it's been out he murders
people that's probably the worst title
movie of all [ __ ] time by the way
no the worst is the cpa no he's a he's a
that sounds worse isn't that just time
with justin timberlake i like naming the
wrong movie every time oh yeah
yeah i thought it was a really cool
concept yeah i do feel like time uh in
the future where it's a commodity and a
tradable good makes sense
but i mean also at the same time you're
being controlled to your death right so
that's weird anyway spoiler alert but um
yeah i would also assume that if i was
working a case and somebody was like hey
you got to go catch that burglar for
some no-name i'd be like yeah it's not
going to happen but if they said that
you had to go catch the burglar from
celebrity i'd be like hey this is a west
house or something yeah this is going to
push my career forward right because i'm
happier though
yeah it puts everyone on the map it's
slightly
it sucks but at the same time it kind of
makes sense and at the same time if
these guys are celebrities they're
probably connected so it could be like
the the the police commissioner is your
dad's best friend or something you know
so what's up with that case you you're
wrong my daughter paris hilton her house
got broken into what's going on with
that you know that's true oh that's the
other side like the glenn maxwell
epstein [ __ ] where it's like two
connected and then you're like hey you
just sweep this under the rush of it
five times just stall this whole thing
out please
actually do
prosecute dealers but it's not news
enough to like say they did it
because it's like oh he wasn't famous
that's true too
why would that be on them but with
colleen it's good because they got her
so
we got her guys we got her isn't it it's
going through a retrial and
they want to [ __ ] call a mistrial on
the first here on the yeah a mistrial
they want to say it's a mistrial because
of the juror spoke the text
they said the juror is biased because he
he
said that he was molested or something
yeah he did and
uh he has a vengeance toward people
that's um you know that are that are
pedophiles the good news is
his hand for like not admitting that he
was yeah but the
lane team is saying that you know what
that's a mistrial so they got gotta
throw out her case now
and we'll see what happens there but she
was convicted so she's guilty we got her
congrats guys and she's convicted of
human trafficking to
you know but that's under seal that's
under seal and they're not going to open
up the books
that's [ __ ] crazy the names but they
don't want to reveal it yeah i wonder
why that's under seal my friend so
we'll see what happens
can people hack [ __ ] like that or is
that like literally like physical
evidence like everything's hackable uh
i don't know if it's on a digital copy
because he wrote down the book
so it's like a physical piece of
evidence it's a physical the ledger's i
mean the the the
black book that everyone's talking about
it's this um kind of guest list that
epstein had
and and they obtained it and there's a
huge list of people in there and there's
confirmation of like bill clinton was in
there several times um you know
just bill gates there's just all these
famous people not a science guy
that would be crazy he says bill knight
the science guy
what are their famous bills
[Laughter]
it says bill gates the microsoft guy
sir l john you got me maybe it could be
could be
order says rocket man
sir ellen john the rocket man
you always gotta add another specific
thing so very detailed knowing they'll
be charged in the future there's a lot
of sections
of washington
you